Mi lavo I capelli o no, lì ho già lavati ieri... vabbè dai me li lavo
Shampoo per capelli ricci per capelli lisci? Beh dipende da come mi faccio la piega e la piega dipende da con mi vesto
spugnetta personale chiaramente
detergente intimo
fondamentale
poi all'appello dovrebbero mancare rasoio scrub
spazzola lo shampoo specifico
Maschera e balsamo nutriente sì abbiamo tutto
🎶🎶🎶
Per che esisto
Vorrei essere più alta. A quella stronza  devo rispondere così: quando la persona è niente l'offesa è zero
E invece mi sono stata zitta come una cretina
Che figura di merda mi sono fatta con Marco però sono passati tre anni magari se lo è dimenticato... speriamo
Ma che cos'è questa spugna che schifo! E questi capelli?
🎶
Mamma mia che capelli rovinati, ma che cosa ho qui dietro?! Oddio!
Ma com'è possibile che perda tutti questi capelli! Lasciatemi in pace vi odio!
La mia vita è una me**a, non ho amici, non ho un fidanzato, nessuno mi vuole!
Odio tutti!
Maschera o non maschera?
Questo è il problema. O Romeo Romeo perché sei tu Romeo? Al mio segnale scatenate l'inferno
Questa magari no. Mi fa pensare al mio ex. Leviamola subitooo
Basta. Mettiamo un po' di reggaeton  che la musica italiana ha un po' rotto
Mamma
Mamma sei tu
Ah forse era il gatto... ma io non ho un gatto! Oddio forse un ladro, vuole rubare e mi troverà a me qui dentro e mi ucciderà
Lo sapevo che prima o poi  ti saresti accorto di me, del mio amore, è da anni che aspetto questo momento. Ti amo
Ma è gelata! Oddio! Ah! Adesso è troppo calda!  Ma è di nuovo fredda!
Mamma
o dimenticate un accappatoio
Me lo porto? ma ancora? Eh ho capito me lo dimentico sempre me lo puoi portare che sto morendo di freddo?
Allora dove ho messo quella crema? Questa no. Questa!
Ed eccoci giunti alla fine
Del video meno male! Così almeno posso asciugarmi. È da tre ore che sono in doccia solo per voi per girare questo video
Fatemi sapere quale di queste tipologie siete è se vi è piaciuto il video mette un bel Like e se non avete ancora fatto
Iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla campanella che trovate il vicino al tasto di iscrizione
e ricevere una notifica ogni volta che pubblico un video e
infine seguite su tutti gli altri social facebook instagram e musicali io adoro